شكرا ليال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
مستمرون معكم عبر العربيه في تغطيتنا
للتطورات في السودان وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه اكدت ان واشنطن تواصل الضغط من
اجل تمديد وقف اطلاق النار هناك واضافت
الخارجيه الامريكيه انها تنسق مع شركاء
اقليميين ودوليين للمساعده في تشكيل لجنه
للاشراف على المفاوضات مشيره الى انها
تسعى لمساعده الفصائل المتحاربه لتحديد
مسار لوقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه وذلك بعد
اتصال مع القاده العسكريين والمدنيين
[موسيقى]
يعني لا مويه لامور لاموات ذات الناس
تستعمله
يوم نحن بنقعد بالح
اله ورافعين الدفاع الجنوني
معقول يعني اللي احنا
من خلق الهدنه
الطرف الاخر
تبادل الاتهامات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بات كتبادل اطلاق النار جزء من يوميات
الحرب الدائره رحاها في شوارع الخرطوم
هدنه اثنتين وسبعين ساعه ما انطلقت حتى
بدات البيانات بالصدور تاره من الجيش الذي
قال انه رصد استمرار التحركات العسكريه
للقوات الدعم داخل وخارج العاصمه ومحاوله
السيطره على مواقع وتقييد تحركات
المواطنين بالاضافه الى حركه كثيفه
بمجموعات متفاوته نحو مصفاه الجيل للسيطره
عليها وخلق ازمه في امدادات الوقود بكامل
البلاد
قوات الدعم السريع من خلال حسابها على
تويتر شجبت انتهاك الجيش الهدنه متهمه
اياه بالقيام بالقصف العشوائي الامر الذي
يعرض حياه المدنيين للخطر هذا الشد والجذب
تزامن مع امال الجهات الدوليه في نجاح
الهدنه حيث حث مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل من خلال
حسابه في تويتر الطرفين على الالتزام حتى
يتم التوصل لوقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
واقامه ممرات انسانيه لحمايه المدنيين
وبعد الاغبياء اما واشنطن حسب وزير
خارجيتها انتوني بلينكين فهي تعمل مع
شركائها لتشكيل لجنه تتفاوض على وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار في السودان
البرهان ودجلو حليفا الامس عدوا اليوم
اللذان تسبب صراعهما على السلطه حتى الان
في قتل اكثر من
459 شخصا حسب الصحه العالميه التي قدرت ان
اعداد الضحايا اكثر من هذا الرقم بكثير اذ
لم يتم احصاء القتلى في مناطق كثيره بسبب
القصف الكثيف انس نماسي العربيه
وقد نشد عدد من المواطنين في السودان عبر
كاميرا العربيه جميع الاطراف هناك لوقف
الاقتتال وتامين حاجيات المواطنين وتامين
المحل التجاريه التي تعرضت للنهب والسلب
خلال الاشتباكات لا للسرغه نحن ما حراميه
نحن سودانيين
يدك على حق غيرك لانه الشعب السوداني تعب
لانه حاصل خلاص في الوطن السودان في غلاء
شديد لا في مويه لا في كهرباء الناس متجهه
لبخاع السودان نسبه لضيق المعيشه في البلد
وعدم توفر الامان ما شايف شرطي واحد في
الشارع لو نزلت الشرطه امنتوا المواطنين
نزلته البنزين نزلت كل الناس هترتاح
نتكلم عن الجنسيه السودانيه وفقط ونتكلم
عن انسان سوداني انسان سوداني محترم لا
يقبل لا يقبل عن يميد يده لحق غيره نتكلم
عن الحوادث السالبه اللي حصلت في المحنه
دي لا لا للحرب منا الحاج يوسف
وكافوري
تحدي التصنيع الحربي وجبل الطير وحجره عسل
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده المئات من موظفيها العاملين
في السودان مع عائلاتهم واوضح مراسل
العربيه في السودان ان عمليه الاجلاء تمت
عبر ميناء بورتسودان
وقد اكد المبعوث الخاص للامم المتحده في
السودان نافولكر بورتس ان مهمه اجلاء
المئات من موظفي الامم المتحده من السودان
كانت صعبه
العمليه الساده احد الوقت اكثر مما كان
مخطط لها ولكن العمليه
العمليه تمت ومشيت بسلام والمهم بالنسبه
لنا كام امم متاخده
انا
جئنا مع هذه القافله من الخاتون لبورت
سودان
وانه حاليا
الاطفال والعائلات على السفينه الفرنسيه
اكدت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للعربيه ان باريس تدعو الى وقف اطلاق
النار لاسباب انسانيه محذره من المواجهات
الدائره في السودان من ان هذه المواجهات
قد تؤدي الى صدمه اقليميه وزعزعه استقرار
المنطقه نذبحه
ندعو الى وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
لاسباب انسانيه السودان كان دوله هشه على
الصعيد الانساني مع وجود نحو اربعه ملايين
نازح قبل هذه الازمه ثلث سكان السودان لهم
احتياجات انسانيه يجب تجنب حصول صدمه
اقلاميه تزعزع استقرار المنطقه وتؤثر على
الدول المجاوره مفوضيه اللاجئين اشارت الى
وجود عدد كبير من النازحين داخل السودان
اضافه الى لاجئين من الذين اجتازوا الحدود
مع تشاد وهذا سيضغط على الدول المجاوره
على الصعيد الانساني
كما قال تناطق باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للعربيه ان عمليه اجلاء الرعايه معقده بعض
الشيء وكان من المفترض ان تتم بعض الحصول
على ضمانات لاجلاء نحو 500 شخص من السودان
انها عمليه معقده ميدانيا ودبلوماسيا
لانها جرت فيما يتواصل القتال في السودان
كان يجب القيام بسلسله اتصالات تسمح
باعطاءنا ضمانات امنيه لاجلاء حوالي 500
شخص من السودان كما هو معلوم تمكننا من
اجلاء رعايانا والطاقم الدبلوماسي وايضا
اجلين عددا كبيرا جدا من الرعايه الاجانب
في السودان
مراسله العربيه كانت رصدت الاجواء في
منطقه المعموره جنوب الخرطوم حيث يحاول
المواطنون وبعض الاجانب مغادره العاصمه
هربا من المعارك
والله ماشيين من حلفا القاهره والله
والله
في الشارع من بيتنا الثاني دخل على شقتي
الرصاص
سكينه دعامه بنص الحله الرصاص تحت عنها
يعني
[موسيقى]
بينا ما في امان النزول حاليا هذه البساط
السفريه تتجه لمناطق مختلفه من
السودان يعني من الولايات وهذا بس تحديدا
يتجه الى القاهره معي هذا الشاب مرحبا
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله شكلك مو مسافر
انت اول حاجه
تموينيه اغراض
مسافرين من الخرطوم فالاوضاع يعني معلومه
يعني تعلمونها جيدا كيف الاوضاع في
السودان عدم توفر مراكز تجاريه عدم توفر
خبز يعني حتى اذا
فتحت
منتظرين في واحد بتاع دكان منتظرين من
الصباح يمكن اكثر من خمس ساعات حتى يفتح
وحتى بنسبه الوضع الخطر حتى لو في تفتح نص
ساعه ساعه وبدون
صعوبه يعني حتى في توفير لقمه العيش في
استغلال تام من
اصحاب الباصات ان اصحاب الباصات بعشرين
لحد اسوان حاليا التذكره ب 300 يعني
بمثابه 300% او اكثر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سودانيون سائقي الحافلات بزياده اسعار
تذاكر السفر من الخرطوم الى ولايه اكثر
امانا الامر الذي اثار غضب واستياء
الاهاليهم اعتبر الكثير من السودانيين
الامر استغلالا واضحا من قبل السائقين
لكسب المال رغم الظروف الصعبه التي تمر
بها البلاد بسبب المعارك المندلعه في
مدنها بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع
استغلال ذاته بشع من اصحاب الاوساط
ويعلي التذكره الصباح بسعر والنسب بسعر
وبعد باكر بيسعد عن الصباح 250 الليله
350 اسوان
القاهره ب 400 الف
اظهرت صور متداوله اطلاق سراح السجناء من
سجن الاندلس جنوب الخرطوم في الكلكلام
مزاجين مدينه الامل
تم اطلاق صراحه الان
مدينه الامل
من امام
القسم مدينه العمل
معنا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم كيف هو الوضع الان
نعم اهلا بكم بكل الساده المشاهدين الوضع
الان هناك
في ولايه الخرطوم مدنها ثلاثه هذا الهدوء
الذي اعتاد عليه المواطنون في اليوم
الماضي كان غدوء نسبيا في الليل كذلك عدا
بعض الاشتباكات القليله لكن بشكل عام هناك
هدوء نسبي في المدن الثلاثه خاصه بعد يوم
شهد فيه السودانيون بعض الاحداث المؤسفه
فيما يتعلق
بمستشفى الرومي في ام درمان هو الذي تعرض
لاعتداء وكان فيه العديد من الاصابات التي
بقيلت على اسمها المستشفى انه بعد ذلك
اضافه الى بعض الاشتباكات التي كانت في
مناطق متفرقه كان ابرزها ما كان في منطقه
الشمال بحري بالقرب من جسر الحلفايه
الرابط
فيما يلي منطقه بحي اي شرق هذا الجسر كانت
هناك اشتباكات عديده وكان هنالك تخص كذلك
في تلك المناطق وتتبع للدعم السريع كانت
متوجهه لمنطقه جري
وفي نصفات الجيده كذلك في هذه المناطق
التي
تجوبها تشوبها العديد من الضبابيه في
التضارب الاخبار من حولها لكن ابرزنا فيها
انه تم قصف مجموعه من العربات التي تدفع
الدعم السريع وهذه العربات كانت متجهه الى
تلك المنطقه
وكذلك كانت هناك عربات ايضا للامداد الدعم
السريع ايضا تم قصفها من الجيش السوداني
كذلك
ثلاثه ايام اللي هدنه المفترضه رغم بعض
الاشتباكات
يعتبرها السودانيون مجرد هدنه لالتقاط
الانفاس ولا امكانيه بالتالي لايجاد حل او
وقف لاطلاق النار دائم في خلالها اقصد
يعني كيف يتعاطى السودانيون انفسهم كيف
يعتبرونها
السودانيون ينتظرون
يعني حاجيات مختلفه ربما عن الاحتياجات
التي يتحدث عنها الطرفين يعني احتياجات
المواطنين تتركز في قضايا واحده منها
الاساسيه الموضوع الامني بكل تاكيد وهو ما
يؤرق المواطنين وما جعلهم كذلك يغادرون
منازلهم لاجئين او ناجحين تماما لانه هذا
ما قصدته لانه ليس لديهم قناعه بانه سيتم
التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار انما هي هدنه
بغض النظر عن صمودها من هشاشتها الا انها
يعني الا ان الطرفين سيعودان الى الاقتتال
مجددا
نعم وهذا ايضا كان واضحا في العديد من
التصريحات التي برزت من كلا الجانبين في
انهم متمسكون بخيار هذه المواجهه
وانهم سيسعون لتحقيق اهدافهم كان اخرها
تاكيدات من الجيش السوداني في انه فاعل
لحسم هذا التمرد بالكامل لانه لن يسمح
بمن يفعل هذه الافاعيل ويتمرد على القياده
العامه وكذلك يكون بلباس يعني يعني يقويها
بلباس قانوني بانه يتبع للجيش وهكذا وهو
يروع المواطنين ويريد انقلاب على المؤسسه
العسكريه بالكامل وكل هذه التفاصيل فهذا
الامر ربما يكون واضحا من هذه الزاويه من
زاويه المواطنين فهم يقرون انه يسعون
لتحقيق وبعض المتطلبات المهمه بالنسبه لهم
في هذه المرحله نتحدث عن
المقيمون هنا في ولايه الخرطوم او الذين
يسعون في هذا الخرطوم وهم يخرجون بعضهم من
المناطق التي تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات الى
مناطق اقل اشتباكا واكثر امنا سعيا منهم
على تحقيق بعض المطالب فيما يتعلق بمياه
الشرب وكذلك توفير المعينات اللازمه في
الامدادات الغذائيه وغيرها من معينات
الحياه بشكل عام هذه الامور كلها هي من
مطالب الذين يودون الاقامه اذا عبرنا الى
الجانب الاخر وهو مساله اللاجئين كذلك
هؤلاء ايضا لديهم العديد من الشكاوى فيما
يتعلق باسعار هذه البوسات
بقدرتهم على دفعها بعد ذلك المصير
المجهوله الذي ينتظر العديد منهم ممن
التقينا بهم في انهم فقط خرجوا لحمايه
اسرهم واطفالهم هذا هو الغرض الاساسي بعد
ذلك للاسف هذه طبيعه الحال في الحروب ساك
تفي معك بهذا القدر للان فقط ولكن لا نعود
اليك في سياق تغطياتنا سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه من الخرطوم من ام درمان ينضم
الينا الصحفي مقداد حسن اهلا بك معنا
استاذ مقداد الوضع الان في ام درمان
تحديدا
اهلا وسهلا بجميع المشاهدين الوضع في ام
درمان التحرير الاحمر يشهد خلو نسبي هنالك
حركه نسبيه لنهار هذا اليوم للاسواق التي
تدعو قليلا عن الاشتباكات مثل اسواق في
ليبيا والسوق الشعبي وكذلك بعض الاسواق
الطرفيه هنالك حركه بسيطه للمواصلات مع
التاكيد على اغلاق الجزء او اغلاق تام
لطلبات الوقود هنالك شعور كبير جدا في
الوقود في منطقه على امتدادها حتى ان
الاسعار اصبحت جنونيه هنالك اشعار مختلفه
لللتر الواحد في منطقه
تختلف عن المنطقه اخرى كلما كلما تحدثنا
عن دخولك الى الى المنطقه المركزيه قربه
هيئه الاذاعه العامه والسلاح الطبي وسلاح
المهندسين حيث تشتد هذه الاشتباكات في هذه
المناطق هنالك شح جدا وغلات الاسعار ومفاج
للمواد الغذائيه بطبيعه الحال لان
المواطنين
يحاولون
الافرار من هذه المنطقه او الذهاب الى
المناطق الاقل اشتباكا هنالك حركه نزوح
نسبي في درمان من المناطق التي تعتبر
مواجهتها وبالتالي السلطات المعنيه يعني
ليس بامكانها اطلاقا ان تقوم بدورها هي
مشلوله تماما لمحاوله كبح جماح الاسعار
محاسبه من يستغل هذه الاوضاع مثلا تامين
الحاجيات الاساسيه المنقطعه
نعم هنالك
شروح كبير جدا
للمواد الغذائيه هنالك ارتفاع جمهوري في
الاسعار هنالك حاله من الفوضى التي تعيشها
البلاد
المتاجر اغلبها مطلقه الكل يخاف على نفسه
ويخاف من الانفلات الامنيه وكذلك العصابات
المتقلده التي قد تنتشر خصوصا مع انتشار
او مع الاشاره المقاديم الذين يعتبرون
خرجوا من سن الهدى
هذا مما يدعوا لحاله من الهلع بين
المواطنين وبالتالي هذا عكس سلبا على حركه
الاسواق في صوره طبيعيه وانعكس كذلك على
حركه المواطنين بصوره طبيعيه اما في
الجانب الصحي في مدينه ام درمان
بهذا اليوم ستعاني اكثر ربما لانه هنالك
مركزا في من الناحيه الشماليه في مدينه
او او هنالك تم استهدافه من
يبدو ان انقطع الاتصال معك مقداد حسن
الصحفي السوداني من ام درمان على كل حال
شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات تحياتي
اليك
تركوا الحرب وراءهم بحثا عن طريق للخروج
من السودان الاف الاشخاص من عشرات
الجنسيات غادروا للوصول الى بر الامان
وعبر وجهات مختلفه كثيرون وجدوا ما تسنى
لهم من وسائل مغادره السودان بحرا او جوا
في حين لجا اخرون للطريق الاصعب بقطع
الجغرافيا السودانيه برا للدول المجاوره
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين في تشاد اعلنت ان
عشرين الف لاجئ وصلوا الى هذا البلد مع
توقعات بان يتبعهم مئه الف اخرون في اسوا
الحالات اما في جنوب السودان فترجح
التقديرات الامميه نزوح ما يصل الى 170
الف شخص ثلاثه ارباعهم من لاجئ جنوب
السودان الذين سيعودون في رحله نزوح جديده
لكن في بلدهم هذه المره حتى من وجدوا
دولهم او دوله ثالثه تمد لهم يد العون فهم
يعانون الامرين لمغادره السودان في رحله
محفوفه النشاق تليها نقاط توقف مؤقته لمن
غادروا برا الى مصر او جوا الى جيبوتي او
بحرا عبر بورسودان وصولا الى السعوديه
حسن جوليد العربيه
وينضم الى هنا في الاستوديو وهشام سلمان
الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني اهلا بك
معنا استاذ هشام مره جديد عبر هذه التغطيه
مرحب كيف تنظر الى هذه الهدنه وكيف توصفها
في ساعاتها الحاليه
انا بتمنى انها تنجح الحضن لانه حقيقه
الوضع المزرع على الارض
والناس بتحاول انها ترتب اموره
على الاقل انه يكونوا في مكان امن هذه
امنياتنا جميعا ولكن كقراءه واقعيه على
الارض هي صامده تتخللها بعض الاشتباكات او
تصفها بغير ذلك السؤال اللي بنساله لنفسنا
يعني انه هل
كل القوه الدوليه بما فيها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
والرباعيه والترويكه ما بتقدر تفرض الهدنه
دي وتثبيتها ولا لا انا بفتكر انه في مقدر
على تثبيت المدنه
في عصا غليظه بتاعت عقوبات ممكن تتطبق
يعني والا لما تقول انه الولايات المتحده
كجزء من الرباعيه لم تقم بدورها الكافي في
هذا الاطار حتى الان انا بفتكر هيشوفوا
الولايات المتحده بتتصرف وفقا
ما لرد الفعل عندها الكلام ده مكرر يعني
الولايات المتحده عندها اصلا اشياء بتتصرف
وفقا ليها القرار 11/5 هو لا زال مبني
عليه واي تصرف خاص لانه القرار 11 خمسه
طلع من الكونجرس بغرفته وبالاغلبيه بدون
اي اعتراض او تحفظ وبالتالي كل المنفذين
منفذين الغرار طبعا بالتاكيد قرار من
الكونجرس بغرفته
وما حد بيقدر يتخطاه وهو للتنفيذ لكن
التنفيذ بيكون فيه
يعني في فيهم مرونه لكن لو لو اضطروا ممكن
يفرضوا عقوبات يعني انت تقول ان البيانات
المتحده لا تريد ان تعيد الامور الى
الوراء كثيرا في العلاقه مع السودان بسبب
هذه الايام من الاشتباكات بالضبط وانا
مبتكرين انه هو في في في احتمال للاغاف
والناس ترجع للتفاوض ما هو حل هو اصلا حتى
الحرب يعني
اولى خطوات التفاوض هي الحرب يعني في علم
الاستراتيجيه لكن هل هم ناويين يتفاوضوا
ولا لا ناويين يعملوا كذا حرب للاخير انا
بفتكر الحرب الاخيره يعني هي مكلفه جدا
مكلفه ولكن ثلاثه ماذا تقول هل هذه ايام
لاجلاءات ولدواعي انسانيه فقط
والاستئناف الحرب بعدها او ربما تتم
مناقشه وقف دائم لاطلاق النارشه لوقف دائم
وفي في مبادره موجوده تمام انه يلتقوا
ويحاولوا يصل لتفاهمات وانا بفتكر انه دي
وارده وارده بشكل كبير الظروف التي لم تكن
قائمه قبل بدايه الحرب يعني حتى توفرت
الان لكي يكون ذلك ممكنا والله هو طبعا
شوف هو الاثنين كل واحد بيقول مين بدا
الحرب يعني انا بفتكر انه الحرب دي بدات
بتقدير خاطئ ونحن التقديرات الخاطئه
بنعاني منها في السودان لفتره السيد حميتي
يقول الان بانه ناقشته مع وزير خارجيه
بريطانيا هاتفيا تطورات الاوضاع في
السودان اذا اتصال هاتفي بين قائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلوه المعروف
بحمايتي ويقول انه ناقش مع وزير خارجيه
بريطانيا هاتفيا تطورات الاوضاع في
السودان اذا كجزء من الرباعيه الدوليه
ايضا بريطانيا يعني سيكون مهما قد يناقش
وقتا اطلاق النار باعتقادك بناء على اي
اساس كما كنا هو يعني
الدعم السريع بيحاول يعني يشرع نفسه دوليا
التع الخارج
وهذا هو دي ملفات بتاعه سياسه يعني يعني
بحاول يلعب دور سياسي خارجي في مع الدول
الرئيسيه
الجيش لا يلام الجيش نفسه وسيد البرهان
تحديدا على شرعنته في الداخل قبل ان
يشرعنوا الخارج او يحاول كسب شرعنه الخارج
هو كان يقول انه هذا جزء منا واصلا يعني
طبعا الدعم السريع صنعوا الرئيس السابق
لحمايته وانا بفتكر انه هو تمدد في الفتره
السابقه ومن مددوا يعني يتحمل البرهان
مسؤوليه في ذلك ما في سيد حماسي يقول الان
بانه وزير خارجيه بريطانيا ثم جهود الدعم
السريع في تامين اجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
والمحسات البعثات الدبلوماسيه انا بفتكر
انه لعب دور كبير جدا في الجيش ولكن نحن
بتهمنا انه هل هل الهدنه دي قابله لانها
تثبت لوقف او تتطور لوقت الاغمار وتتطور
لتفهمات توقف القلب تحت الحرب ولا لا انا
بالنسبه
هي المهمه وهي المفروض تتناغش وهي المفروض
انه يتواجد لها اليات لتطبيقها انا شايف
ما هي ابرز الاليات التي يجب ان يتم
مناقشتها عند عرض وقف اطلاق النار هو في
مبادره هو يفترض السلحين مقدمه مقدمه
المجتمع المدني والاحزاب السياسيه
المبادره دي هي بتتشكل من ثلاثه نقاط يعني
على اساس انها ثلاثه مع انه انا بقيت اتش
من كلمه ثلاثه مراحل وثلاثه
لكن اول شيء
وقف اطلاق النار وبعدين يتثبت لي وقفي
نايم وبعدين يتم لقاء سياسي لانه الخلاف
خلاف سياسي اكثر شيء لانه خلاف على السلطه
والثروه ما خلاف على
ما خلاف والكل بيدعي منه ولا لا هو
المدنيون هنا ده التدخل هذا التدخل من
المجتمع المدني في انه هو يحاول يفرض
شروطه انا دائما بقول انه احنا ما بتهمنا
الاجنده بتاعت
بتاعه الدعم السريع ولن الاجنده بتاعت
الجيش بتهم من الاجنده بتاعت الشعب
السوداني الشعب السوداني عنده اجنده الشعب
السوداني عنده اجنده بتتلخص في التغيير
ويقول سقف التغيير ده هو الانتقال المدني
الديمقراطي بس لم يستطع ان يفرض شروطه
للاسف والله شوف هو المجتمع المدني انا
بفتكر انه نحن عندنا خطا في تناول
المبادره يعني هل السياسيين موظفوا كل
الامكانيات بتاعت الشعب السوداني في
الوصول للسقف بتاع الانتقال المدني
الديمقراطي ام لا
لم يفعلوا ذلك
انا باجي انه كان في اخطاء لماذا كان في
اخطاء في سوق التقدير يمكن قلت لك سوء
التقدير يعني شوف سوء التقدير ده ملازم
لكل المشهد الكام موجود يعني انا لو جيت
عدم درايه كافيه او او مصالح او علاقات
مصالح بتغطي
بتحجيب الرؤيه الصحيحه يعني سوء التقدير
مثلا لو انا جيت للعسكريين
سوء تقدير كان ثمانيه رمضان
سوء تقدير فضل الاعتصام سوء تقدير انقلاب
الاجراءات التصحيحيه
نعم برضو سوء تقدير وفي النهايه هم
يحترفوا وقالوا فشلنا
الحرب في نص العاصمه
واخلد بكل الامن والسلم بتاع المواطنين
على امل ان تاتي بوقت اطلاق نار دائم ان
كان من ثلاثه او اربعه او خمس او ست مراحل
لوجودك معنا استاذ هشام سلمان الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني
[موسيقى]
اذا حماتي يقول نؤكد التزامنا الكامل بوقف
النار خلال الهدنه وملتزمون بالتعاون
لاجلاء رعايه الدول الراغبه في ذلك كان
قال ايضا انه ناقش مع وزير خارجيه
بريطانيا هاتفيا تطورت الاوضاع في السودان
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ثمن جهوده كما
قال حميتي جهود الدعم السريع في تامين
اجلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه صحيفه
فشلت بعمليه الانتقال الديمقراطي في
السودان بعد ان حفزت المنافسه بين طرفي
الصراع في البلاد
عمليه التحول الديمقراطي والانتقال للحكم
المدني في السودان فشلت وانتهت بالفوضى
وبوادر حرب اهليه والسبب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقول صحيفه وولز جورنال الصحيفه
اعتبرت ان واشنطن اخطات في قراءه الوضع
السياسي في الخرطوم وحفزت المنافسه بين
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف بحمدتي
على بناء قوتيهما وتحديدا بعد تبني سياسه
اصلاح قطاع الامن في السودان بما يضمن وضع
الرجلين تحت السيطره المدنيه وهذا الامر
لم تصدقه الا واشنطن تقول الصحيفه
الامريكيه منذ الاستقلال عام
1956 شهد السودان سبعه عشره انقلاب نجحت
منها سته وحربين اهليتين وصراع اباده
جماعيه في دارفور ورغم هذا لم تقرا واشنطن
جيدا المشهد السياسي في السودان مما ادى
الى اتجاه البلاد نحو الانهيار ومعها
العمليه الديمقراطيه التي دعمتها واشنطن
منذ الاطاحه بالرئيس السابق عمر البشير
عام 2019
ابعد من ذلك فشلوا الحسابات السياسيه
للاداره الامريكيه ادى الى جذب انتباه
روسيا والصين حيث تعتبر السودان ارض الذهب
والنفط والموارد المعدنيه الاخرى وربما
لاجل كل هذه التشابات حذر الامين العام
للامم المتحده من ان الصراع في السودان قد
يبتلع المنطقه كلها محاسن حداره العربيه
من لندن الكاتب الصحفي خالد الاعسر اهلا
بك معنا استاذ خالد هل تتفق مع ما ذهبت
اليه بشان تحميل المسؤوليه او جانب كبير
منه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه في تحفيز
طرفي النزاع
تحيه لك والضيوفكم الكرام بالتاكيد اتفق
مع هذه الرؤيه والشواهد خلال الاعوام
الماضيه حتى بعد صعود نظام الرئيس المعزول
عمر البشير ظلت الاداره الامريكيه تلعب
ادوار يعني غير متوازنه سياسيا هي التي
دفعت بالكثير من القرارات ولكن لهم توفي
بشروط هذه العوده التي قطعتها على نفسها
بدءا من عمليه رفع العقوبات التي اشترطت
فيها اوتوات وجيه زياده فعل رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق عبد الله حمدوك 335 مليون دولار في
سبيل رفع العقوبات وحاسبت السودان على
تفجير المدمره كول وايضا تفجير السفارتين
في نيروبي ودار السلام وهي جميع اعمال لم
يقم بها السودان بصوره مباشره ولا حتى
تورط في عمليا جاءت الفتره الانتقاليه وهي
دفعت باتجاه دعم
مكونات سياسيه بعينها وتمرير اجندات على
امل ان تتحكم بعض القوه المدنيه الصغيره
في المشهد السياسي السوداني ولكنها فشرت
في كثير من المرات وفي كل المرات في واقع
الام وهذا يؤكد ان الاداره الامريكيه لم
تنظر للسودان نظره موضوعيه ولم تتدارس هذا
الشان بعمق
جزء من
الثلاثيات الرباعيات والاتحادات الكثيره
التي دخلت على خط الازمه السودانيه منذ
سنوات عده لماذا تحملها المسؤوليه
منفرده هناك الرباعيه الدوليه فيها
بريطانيا حيث انت ايضا
والامارات والسعوديه هناك ايضا دول اخرى
الاتحاد الافريقي مثلا ايضا على خط الازمه
منذ فتره اضافه الى الامم المتحده
والمبعوث الاممي
اذا نظرت الى كل هذه المكونات الثلاثيه
والرباعيه وكل هذه الاسماء والاشكال ستجد
ان المحرك الاساس لكل الحراك السياسي في
السودان وعمليه الوساطه كانت يضبط اغاعه
المبعوثه الاموي
بغرار مجلس الامن الذي صدر وفوض البعثه
العموميه المعروفه الدعم الانتقال في
السودان كل المجهودات التي تمت هي تصطدم
وفق الرؤيه التي تصير على تنفيذها البعثه
الاماميه المدعومه من الاداره الامريكيه
وهي يعني انتخاء انتقال نخبه سياسيه قليله
صغيره لم تخد عمليا انتخابيه على من قبل
الا حزب الامه لكن بغيت العذاب الثلاثه
التي لعبت حتى فيما بالاتفاق الايطالي
والحوار مع المكون العسكري وهنا لا نلغي
بالله ما فقط على القوه المدنيه المقاومه
العسكريه نفسه كانت لها اخطاء كبيره جدا
لانه ساق في عمليه تفاوض للمره الثالثه مع
القوه المدنيه في معارك بالاتفاق الايطالي
وهو الذي ايضا اغر فكره مبدا اطراف
الاتفاق وهذه كانت عقبه كبيره وكل هذا
يحمل المسؤوليه للاليه الاليه الامميه
ولكن اداره امريكيه بحكم ما لديها من
تاثير بحكمها لديها من علاقات بحكمه لديها
من قدرات كان يمكن ان تدفع باتجاه حل
سياسي شامل ترسيخ لقيم الديمقراطيه التي
يبعد ما يكون عنها في الملف السوداني هي
تتحدث عن الديمقراطيه
تصوير الموضوع على انه الكل في الداخل
روبوتات يتحركون بكبسات زر من واشنطن يعني
قد يكون مبالغ فيه في قيادات جيش عريقه في
السودان في شخصيات سياسيه عريقه في احزاب
عريقه وفي اراده شعبيه مثل ما صار
بالثورات الكبرى اللي نازل فيها الشعب
السوداني
ثم انه قوات الدعم السريع يعني لم تخلقها
الولايات المتحده هي كانت موجوده من ايام
النظام السابق واستمرت وكان هناك قيادات
يعني ساهمت في تعزيز دورها وفي محاوله
الاصرار على دمجها بالجيش والى ما هنالك
من الكلام الذي بدنا نعرفه جميعا
واذا نظرت الى التاريخ التي بدات باتهامات
كبيره في صياغه حقوق الانسان والتعدي على
المواطنين العزل في دارفور وتمرحله
المساله حتى حتى وصلت مرحله الدعم السريع
وبالتاكيد القوى المدنيه التي رفعت شعارات
في ميدان الاعتصام يعني
تشدد من الدوره الوطني لقوات الدعم السريع
وعادت وارتدت من جديد لتجرم الدعم السريع
وفي مره لاحقه عادت لتعتلف من جديد هناك
تضارب كبير تم في صياغه العمل السياسي
المحلي الداخلي لكن انا لا الغي بالله ما
فقط على الغور المدنيه المؤسسه العسكريه
ممثله في قيادات ايضا تمهد اكثر مما يجب
مع الدعم السريع وخلقت منه القدره منحته
ان يكون القدره لديه قدره عسكريه ضخمه
بالتاكيد المشهد السياسي خلال 4 اعوام
ونصف الماضيه كان مفتوحا على مصرعي
للتدخلات الدوليه بشكل لم يكن مسبوق على
مر التاريخ لم يعد هناك اي صوت وطني
يستطيع ان يفرض او يقترح اجندات محليه كل
المحاول الوطنيه التي جرت من قبل شخصيات
وطنيه لم تلقى لم يلغي لها بال بل جرم كل
من تقدم بمشروع وطني وبالتالي ما تفضلت به
هو ليس صحيح المجتمع الدولي والاراده
الدوليه والاقليميه كانت سلطه عليا وكثير
من المكونات المحليه كانت تنفذ وتلبي شروط
الخارج حتى المبادرات الوطنيه في عدد من
المبادرات رفضت وصنف اصحاب اما انهم اتباع
للنظام القديم فلول او كيزان او يعني
ياتمر بامر الولايات المتحده قوات الدعم
السريع كان تعتمر بامر القوات الولايات
المتحده الاحزاب السودانيه شخصيات
القياديه رئيس الوزراء السابق الحمدوك كله
لم يستطع احد تغيير شيء الا بامر من
الولايات المتحده لانها لم تكن تريد ذلك
هذا ما تريد ان تقوله
انا الذي اريد ان اقوله هناك ضغوط دوليه
كبيره مورثه على الكثير من المكونات من
بين الجيش السوداني الذي تعرض لمؤامرات
كبيره هناك حملات واستهداف كبير تم للجيش
السوداني ايضا يعني دعك من كل الافكار
الاخرى الجيش الذي تخرج المواكب بكل اسف
حتى المواكب انا طبعا
اقول رايي بصراحه يعني الشعب السوداني
برضو هناك من سعره في الطرقات واسسوا
لثوره عظيمه جدا ولكنهم بلعوا الطعم الذي
دفعهم بحكم محركات الكترونيه من الخارج
عبر غرف الكترونيه تسيء للجيش الوطني الذي
هو الان يقاوم مدافع عن الشعب السوداني
بكل مكوناته سواء كان يسار او لجام مقاومه
او هو يمنيه وبالتالي هناك تضليل لكن
الجيش السوداني كانت لديه قياده تمهد في
عدد من المرات بما لا يلبي طموحات الشعب
وهي ربما مدفوعه بضغوط داخليه وخارجيه او
حتى مخدوعه بفكره من يمثلون الشارع
السوداني في ست ابريل الحالي
المواكب ترفض الجيش وترفض المكونات
السياسيه والجيش وقع الاتفاقيه المعروفه
بوثيقه الدستوريه على عمل ان الذين وقعوهم
من يمثلون الشعب السوداني بينما هم الشعب
السوداني رفضوا في 6 ابريل وظل يرفضهم
طوال العوامه الماضيه انا اشعر بان هناك
يعني حاله تدافع لخطبوط المجتمع الدولي
حتى التصريحات التدافع الذي نشهد الان من
سعد في الرعايه ومن سهل هذا يعني محاولات
لخط بمده المجتمع الدولي لتحقيق شروط
وواجبات والتزامات تخدم افراد يعني لماذا
يتدافع الدعم السريع في الجهه والجيش من
جهه اخرى لكي يتحدث كل طرف على انه هو
الذي سهل عمليه اجداره الرعايه الاجانب
والذي يدفع الذي يدفع هو محاوله لخطبه
المجتمع الغربي من مكونات العسكريه وهذا
امر مرفوض الذي يتداعى ليخدم المجتمع
الدولي ويخطبوط في سبيل اخراج الرعايه
الاولى ان يتداعى ويوقف اطلاق النار ويجلس
في طاوله لكي ينقذ الشعب السوداني قبل
التفكير في انقاذ الخارج ان شاء الله تكون
دعوه وصلت شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ خالد
الاعسر الكاتب الصحفي من لندن تحياتي اليك
وسط مساعد دول في اجلاء راعيها من السودان
بما فيها الولايات المتحده يعادل الذاكره
التجربه الامريكيه في افغانستان تجربه
تختلف تماما عن السودان لما تواجهه واشنطن
اليوم من تحديات امنيه كبيره لاجلاء
رعايرها
وسط هموم السودان تبرز معضله للدول
الراغبه في اجلاء مواطنيها وخاصه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
تجربه افغانستان لا يمكن ان تعاد بالنسبه
كان الاجلاء من مطار كابول ممكنا كونه تحت
السيطره الامريكيه اما في السودان فالوضع
مختلف
حال المطارات هنا لا يساعد مطار الخرطوم
تحت القصف المستمر وباقي المطارات لا تخلو
من المشكلات وربما هذا ما دفع البيت
الابيض للاقرار بالحقيقه
تجربه نقل الدبلوماسيين باعدادهم المحدوده
كانت ممكنه لكن الطريقه ذاته لم يكن ممهدا
امام نقل مدنيين متفرقين باعداد هائله وسط
هدن لا سلام فيها فلا اخلاء دون وقف طويل
لاطلاق النار لضمان سلامه المدنيين خطه
نقل جماعي برا هذا ما تدرسه وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لنقل مواطنيها من الخرطوم فبعد
قصف متبادل لا ينقطع في محيط المطارات
تستخدم امريكا قدراتها الاستخباراتيه في
مراقبه الطرق وتوقع التهديدات الناجمه عن
اجلاء بري محتمل
الطريق الى ارجين البري الحدود السودانيه
المصريه طريق بري عرضه 80 مترا على بعد
850 كيلو مترا من العاصمه الخرطوم شمالا
خطه تصطدم بتحديات امنيه كبيره خلال نقل
المواطنين الامريكيين من السودان الى مصر
طريق بري اخر وصولا الى ميناء بورتسودان
البوابه الشرقيه للسودان تبعد عن العاصمه
الخرطوم مسافه
675 كيلومترا نشرت امريكا سفونا فيها
كبديل اخر لاجلاء مواطنيها عبر البحر
الاحمر تضع امريكا خططا بديله قيد الدراسه
لنقل 16,000 امريكي في السودان وسط معركه
تتعقد ساعه بعد اخرى وهدى تتوالى لم يكتب
لاي منها الصمود غذاء السالم العربيه
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه انها لا
تخطط للمزيد من رحلات الاجلاء الالمانيه
من السودان مشيره الى ان اخر رحله اجلاء
من السودان الى الاردن ستنطلق مساء اليوم
واضافت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان دولا شريكه
ستتولى اجلاء المواطنين الالماني المتبقين
في السودان خلال الايام المقبله
اعلنت هيئه اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه عن
انهائها عمليات الاجلاء نحو جيبوتي وانها
ابقت على فرقاطه في بورتسودان لمساعده
الامم المتحده على عمليات الاجلاء نحو جده
كما اكدت وزاره الخارجيه والدفاع الفرنسيه
في بيان مشترك ان عدد الجنسيات التي
استفادت من عمليات الاجلاء الفرنسيه ارتفع
الى 41 جنسيه واشار البيان ايضا الى ان
عمليات الاجلاء حصلت من نقاط التجمع في
الخرطوم نحو قاعده وادي سيدنا ومن القاعده
جوا الى جيبوتي
قالت قوات الدعم السريع في السودان انها
تنسق مع البعثات الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات
الاقليميه والدوليه ما اسهم في اجلائها
الى اماكن امنه واكدت قوه الدعم السريع في
بيان انها متمسكه بالهدنه مشيره الى ان
هذا الالتزام نابع من مسؤوليتها الاخلاقيه
ومن التزامها للدول التي طالبت بتجديد
الهدنه لفتح ممرات انسانيه
تنضم الينا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب
العربيه في الخرطوم لينا يعقوب اهلا بك
لينا مره جديده في الاستوديو ونريد ان
نعرف منك اخر المعلومات ما الذي تسمعينه
من الداخل اهلا بك يا طاهر مساء الخير
هناك معلومات من الجانب الرسمي وهو هناك
معلومات من شارع السوداني تحدثنا عن
المعلومات من الجانب الرسمي فاخر بيان
صادر هو للجيش السوداني يتحدث عن استقرار
الاوضاع خاصه في الولايات السودانيه وكان
قبل هذا البيان يتحدث عن خروقات للخدمه من
جانب الدعم السريع في بعض المواقع في
الخرطوم كذلك بحري وام درمان شهود عيان
يتحدثون عن السماع اطلاق النار وكذلك بعض
اصوات المدافع تاتيهم في المدن الثلاثه
الخرطوم بحري وام درمان في ضغط الوقت هم
يتحدثون عن انتشار لقوات الدعم السريع في
مواقع وكذلك سيطره الجيش في مواقع اخرى
هذا يعني ان الامر الميداني او المعركه
الميدانيه لم تحسم حتى اللحظه بصوره كامله
للجيش السوداني هذا في العاصمه ولكن في
بقيه الولايات عندما يقول الجيش انه الوضع
مستقر هو فعلا كذلك يعني ليس هناك اي
اشتباكات او اي محاولات من قوات الدعم
السريع للسيطره في مناطق اخرى فقط المناطق
الثلاث في الخرطوم العاصمه في معظم
الولايات السودانيه الاوضاع مستقره ولكن
مثلا في ولايه دارفور لم تكن كذلك كان
هناك قتل وكثير من الاصابات وحالات من
النهب والسرقه والتدمير للاسواق وسرقه
المنازل وكانت هناك الكثير من الاعمال
الاجراميه في بعض مدن دارفور ولكن هنا في
الخرطوم هي الاكثر ضررا بعد ذلك هناك
ولايات مستقره مثل القضارف كسلا بورسودان
سنار الجزيره
هذه مستقره تمام
والسودانيون ينزحون اليها الان من الخرطوم
القليل من السوداني من العاصمه الان
ينزحون اليها نسبه العدد السودانيين
الكبير ولكن هناك حالات نزوح هناك
احصائيات من الامم المتحده تتحدث من 10
الى
12,000 سوداني ينزحون الى خارج السودان
طبعا عبر المنافذ المختلفه معروف ان
للسودان حدود مع ليبيا تشاد جنوب السودان
ومصر
وغيرها ولكن اكثر المعابر التي فيها
نزوح او فيها سفر الى الخارج هي اثيوبيا
القاهره وكذلك هناك بعض المحاولات للسفر
عبر البحر الى جده ولكن ايضا هذه لا تتم
هي الان للرعايه الاجانب وليس لي
السودانيين من خلال عمليات الاجلاء التي
نتابعها اولا باول اذا يمكن ان نقول بانه
الهدنه صامده
ولكن تتخللها بعض الاشتباكات التي ربما لا
تؤثر على بقائها
وفقا لما يردنا من الارض الهن طاهر هي
لابد ان ان يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق النار
وحريه للحركه وتوفر الاساسيات الحياه يعني
هذا الامر لا يتم مع الهدنه
والهدنه التي يقال انها تستمر سابقا ثلاثه
ساعات ثم زادت الى 24 ساعه ثم زادت الى 72
ساعه لم يحدث ان استمرت كلها دون اي اطلاق
نار صحيح ان هناك عمليات اجلال لكن هناك
مراعاه لربما لان لا يصاب احد من رعايه
الدول الاجنبيه باي اذى تكون هناك بعض
الحسابات العسكريه لهذا الامر ولكن هناك
اطلاق نار يحدث اليوم في ام درمان عاده ما
يكون ايضا في محيط القصر الجمهوري في وسط
الخرطوم هذا امر يعني لا مفر منه يحدث
يوميا منذ ان بدات هذه الاشتباكات قبل
اكثر من عشره ايام نامل ان يكون الحرص على
عدم اصابه او قتل المواطن قبل اي احد اخر
من من جنسيات اخرى ولعله
صوت دائما بالدعوه الى السلام يعني يصل
عبر شاشه العربيه شكرا جزيلا يعقوب مديره
مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم شكرا على هذه
المعلومات
امنه ما في طردونا من سودان
ناكل ونشربه
ولا عندهم اكل ولا شرف
لاهم الانباء اعلن نائب وزير الدفاع
البريطانيه
من بينها قذائف يورانيوم منظم وقال وزاره
الدفاع لا تتعقب الاماكن التي تستخدم فيها
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ذخيره
اليورانيوم المنطب
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السويديه طردها خمسه
مسؤولين في السفاره الروسيه في السويد
وذلك بسبب قيامهم بانشطه لا تتوافق مع
اتفاقيه فيينا للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه فيما
لم تحدد الوزاره طبيعه هذه الانشطه في
المقابل اعلنت الخارجيه الروسيه عن طرد
موظف في سفاره مولدوفا في اطار المعامله
بالمثل حيث تم استدعاء السفير فوق العاده
والمفوض لجمهوريه مولدوفا لدى روسيا وقدمت
له مذكره احتجاج على اجراءات مولدوفا غير
الوديه تجاه روسيا
اكدت شركه طيران الوطنيه البولنديه رفض
صعود لاعب التنس روسيه على متن احدى
رحلاتها ما تسبب بردود فعل غاضبه من
رياضيين على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وقالت لاعبه التنس فيتاليا
انها كانت تحاول السفر لحضور بطوله في
كورسيكا عبر وارسو ونيس ومنعت من الصعود
على متن رحله طيران تابعه لشركه طيران
الوطنيه البولنديه كما رفضت شركه الطيران
الالمانيه
بيع تذكره لها
دعا وزير الخارجيه
امينه العام للامم المتحده
بما في ذلك اللجنه الرباعيه التي قال عنها
انها اصبحت ضحيه للاسطاء الدوليين مثل
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي في
المقابل اكد منسق الامم المتحده الخاص
لعمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط على عدم
شرعيه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه بالاراضي
الفلسطينيه بموجب القانون الدولي وانها
تشكل عقبك كبيره في طريق السلام بين
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
اجرى وزير الدفاع الروسيه
رباعيه في موسكو مع نظرائه في ايران
وسوريا وتركيا وقالت وزاره الدفاع التركيه
ان الوزاره ان الوزراء ناقشوا خلال
الاجتماع تعزيز الامن في سوريا وتطبيع
العلاقات بينها وبين تركيا في المقابل
نقلت صحيفه الوطن السوريه عن مصدر لم
تسميه القول انه لا صحه للبيان الذي بثته
وزاره الدفاع التركيه والذي تحدث عن خطوات
ملموسه تتعلق بتطبيع العلاقات بين تركيا
وسوريا
اعلنت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مقتل احد
عناصرها بعد تعرض سياره القتيل لقصف من
طيران مسير تركي في منطقه كوبا نيشان
البلاد بدوره افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان بمقتل شخصين واصابه الثالث بجروح
خطيره جراء استهداف طائره مسيره تركيه
جنوب كوباني والتي تقع ضمن مناطق سيطره
قوات قصد في ريف حلب الشرقيه
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 24 ليصبح بعمر
الثمانين عاما كاكبر مرشح يخوض حمله جديده
الى البيت الابيض وكتب على تويتر انه
متمسك بالدفاع عن الديمقراطيه مشيرا الى
ان الحريات الشخصيه في امريكا تتعرض لهجوم
من الجمهوريين المتطرفين بحسب تعبيره
هذا وهزم الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب الرئيس جو بايدن بعد اعلان الاخير
ترشحه
وتوعد ترامب في مقطع مصور بايضا بالهزيمه
وانقاذ الاقتصاد اضافه الى منع اندلاع حرب
عالميه ثالثه على حد قوله
مع مثل هذه الرئاسه الفاشله من غير
المعقول ان يفكر بيض فترشح لاعاده انتخابه
انت تعرف ما حدث في الانتخابات الاخيره
لقد غشوا وزوروا الانتخابات لكنني اعدك
بهذا عندما اقف في تلك المرحله من
المناظره واقارن سجلتنا سيكون هذا اسوا
كابوس للديمقراطيين الراديكاليين لانه لم
يكن هناك سجل بهذا السوء ابدا لم يكن هناك
ابدا تناقض اكبر بين ادارتين متتاليتين في
كل التاريخ الامريكي بدعمكم في الانتخابات
سنهزم جو بايدن في عام 2024 سنقذ اقتصادنا
سنسحق التضخم سنوقف الغزو على حدودنا
الجنوبيه سنعيد كرامه امتنا وسنمنع اندلاع
الحرب العالميه الثالثه
نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه مقتطفات من
خطاب وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس يرسموا
السياسه الخارجيه للحكومه حيال باكين
وسيحض الخطاب على تفادي سياسه العزل الحيل
الصين وتجنب الحديث عن حرب بارده جديده
وسيدعو كليفر الى انخراط بناء مع بكين
يشمل القضايا الدوليه الرئيسه كما سيتعهد
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني بتعزيز الامن
القومي في مواجهه تنامي قدرات بكين
العسكريه والتعاون مع الحلفاء
اعلن الهلال الاحمر الليبي في بيان عن
انتشال احدى عشر جثه لمهاجرين من بينهم
طفله بعد غرق قاربهم ليرتفع اجمالي عدد
الجثث التي تم انتشالها الى 34 جثه خلال
الايام الخمس الماضيه وجاء في البيان ان
القارب المتجه الى اوروبا كان يحمل 80
مهاجرا من بلدان مختلفه كانت الحدود
الجنوبيه لليبيا تشهد في السنوات الماضيه
عبور الاف المهاجرين املا في الوصول الى
اوروبا
اعتمد البرلمان الليتواني قانونا يشرع
ابعاد المهاجرين الذين يحاولون عبور
الحدود بشكل غير قانوني وقالت وزير
الداخليه ليتوانيا
انه في ظل السياق الجيو السياسي العالمي
الحالي فعل ليتوانيا ان تحمي نفسها عبر كل
الادوات الممكنه ومن جهتها اعربت المنظمات
الحقوقيه عن قلقها واعتبردت ان الحكومه
تضفي شرعيه على ممارسات غير قانونيه تنتهك
حقوق طالبي اللجوء
قال وزير الزراعه الاسباني ان بلاده طلب
التمويلا طارئا من الاتحاد الاوروبي لدعم
المزارعين ومربي المشي بسبب موجه الجفاف
التي تشهدها اسبانيا واضاف الوزير ان
اسبانيا طلبت المساعده لنحو 890 الف عامل
زراعي من صندوق احتياطي الازمات الزراعيه
في الكتله وصناديق التنميه الريفيه غير
المستغله
ووصف الوزير الاسباني للمساعده الماليه
العاجله بانها ذات اهميه قصوى
شكرا لمتابعتكم هذه الساعه الاخباريه
تغطيه المستمره من العربيه يتابع فيها
صهيب شرايط بعد قليل الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قنات
نا الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات